I know and have experiences of knowing
that religion not Islam actually but
Christianity some forms of Christianity
can be very bad
but the Level Society I look around and
I'm kind of going
[Music]
you said it yourself you need something
that's above you you need something that
connects you to other people you need
the community in a world that's becoming
increasingly detached from in which we'd
become detached from each other
I don't know that we've come up with
yeah an alternative work people have
and I'm like you know what I I'd rather
be an Anglican if that's the choice
you mentioned being an atheist I when I
was probably 18 20 that I found that way
of thinking very appealing now I'm
agnostic and I think that's likely where
I'm gonna stay but I you hear a lot of
people talk about the fact that
and I have some sympathy with this
argument that the
decreasing religiousness of the West has
allowed things like wokeness to step
into that void what do you as an atheist
make of that argument I think it's a
interesting argument and um makes me
very uncomfortable I can imagine but um
but yeah I think there's um
it's fascinating and
adds a complication to
you know what I would as an atheist
prefer to to think and and be true about
the world and human nature really
um and how we optimize for the best kind
of society
I would
prefer that a society in which no
there's no religion
um
you know and also somehow we have solved
for Dogma you know the Dogma that might
come in other forms
um I think that's the best Society of
all sure but is that a song is that is
that a possible Right Society probably
not um is it is it possible for us to
not have religious Dogma
um and to also somehow restrict uh
resist every other kind of Dogma
um is that a possible World
um so from that perspective you know uh
a a
secular but religious does that make
sense yeah world is
in some ways worse you know the worst of
all you know possible outcomes you know
maybe maybe even as bad as ancient you
know religious contexts
um yeah so that's I I I I think that's a
very interesting train of thought I I'm
not sure where I end up there
at the moment
I do think that there is um
psychological need I think for the
comfort of some kind of transcendental
values you know I think they can be
routed in other ways I don't think you
need God but I think you need them to be
bigger than you
um and you need it to be something that
draws you into the collective and to
people around you and something that
gives you this sense of belonging and
personal significance but also
and this is a word that never doesn't
get used enough Duty towards others you
know like not just that I belong here
and you make me feel great and
personally significant that's that's
wonderful but also what do you owe them
what do you owe your fellow man
um I think that's that
idea of Duty is what is a Cornerstone of
communities you know and we're seeing
the fraying of communities
a little bit maybe yeah
um insofar as we can't find something
else insofar as that we can't address
this problem in some other creative way
but ultimately I think this is where
modernity is going
um
uh this is what you know this is the
path that we're walking down
um sort of alienation from each other
from physical the you know the physical
world from uh broader uh you know the
world around us our neighbors that kind
of thing we're we're increasingly
alienated from I mean that's a modernity
challenge can you bring religion back
and say that this is the so this is the
solution I don't know I don't know if
you can force yourself to believe
something that is
you know
not true I don't think I could I think
that even if I thought religion was very
good I don't think I could go back to it
well this is where I am because
I think really I know and have
experiences of knowing that religion not
Islam actually but Christianity some
forms of Christianity can be very bad
and Islam clearly there are some forms
of that or some people who follow it who
can be very bad
but the level of society I look around
and I'm kind of going
[Music]
there was you said it yourself you need
something that's above you you need
something that connects you to other
people you need the community in a world
that's becoming increasingly detached
from in which we become detached from
each other
I don't know that we've come up with
yeah an alternative work people have and
I'm like you know what I I'd rather be
an Anglican if that's the choice
anglicanism works for me compared to
this crap that's not really a religion
anymore is it well it's you know let's
not get into that we have five minutes
left or whatever you know what I mean
yeah so so how can we advocate for well
not Advocate but how can we say well you
know agnosticism is good or being an
atheist is good when we look around and
we go the Practical consequences of the
lack of religion are bad
um yeah I wouldn't say that it's exactly
the Practical consequences of a lack of
religion I think they're all uh
that the lack of religion and the the
uh
incidents more more woke is I'm in the
world or more sensitive alienation
they're all being caused by another
Factor you know that's happening
together that that is it seems to me
that there's nothing we can really do
about with the tools that we have at our
at our disposal at the moment you mean
technology
technology has a big role to play in the
overall alienation that we feel and the
various social consequences I mean you
can't even use you think of the social
fabric it doesn't even make sense to
think of it as a fabric it's not a
fabric where individual threads floating
around and we're knotted up in one piece
or another in one online community or
space and and and uh isolated there
um
I think the problem is a bigger one and
I don't know if old religion has the
tools to solve it partially because well
it makes a lot of claims about the real
world and they they have an effect
um not a good one and it is hard to get
the you know a 17 year old to believe in
the the literal truth of of something
that's making claims that are not true
in the natural world and we know for a
fact and they know for a fact you can't
hide this from them anymore so the ways
in which religion is literally not true
is a hurdle that I don't know if it can
overcome
um insofar as we're we're considering
what is a solution
to you really I mean that's the so
that's that what the solution is what
would it be that would change you well
we've been sitting so our friends who
were staying with here they're they're
Christians and we've been we've spent
every night sitting right around here
arguing this back and forth and there's
not they haven't they're very clever
people yeah and I respect them very much
but they there's nothing that can
convince me
of that but on the other hand
I am extremely convinced that without
Community without connection which they
have because if you're a Christian you
go to church you have a community the
way you relate to other people is
different and so on
you know without that human beings are
not designed to live in this world that
we live in now when we're not designed
we didn't evolve so triggering work to
an atheist we did not evolve to live
alone to live in disconnected
disembodied life
um and so I feel it's you know
particularly I became a father recently
I'm thinking about this like what are we
offering people
because this disembodied disconnected
existence is not good for us no no
no it's it's fraying away at
important element of human existence
like I mean not to be to to grandiose
about it but I think it's true that um
relationships you know sex people are
having sex people aren't happy people
don't have friendships people are
isolated and Alone
um uh and plugged into these digital
spaces that are very toxic and damaging
to them they are encouraged to conceive
of themselves as
as the end product right as the pitcher
at the end that you post on your profile
um and in the video that you take of
yourself is almost a performer first
um and to think about
yourself in third person
um all the time and to be signaling all
the time it's a very it's an exhausting
way to live and I think it's a it's not
it's not a surprise to me that
Zoomers are you know they're just [__]
up they're they're you know they have
they have a lot of problems
um and it seems like not a lot of
solutions
I don't have an answer for you and I
just don't think that
it would be nice maybe if we can have a
nice form of Christianity
can we though can we you know pass that
on to a 13 year old that has access to
the internet and finds Reddit atheism
and and they're all like this is why
it's wrong and then you stop believing
right
um so long as we don't have a choice in
the matter of belief or not belief
it is important that they are making
literal claims about the world that are
not not true
um and I think we'll
affect their the ability of an even a
nice Christianity to go very far
um in moving people and pulling them
away from uh from the disconnectedness
that we're seeing around us there has to
be some other solution but I you know I
I was in charge of creating communities
when I was you know in
running my organization and it was a
very
interesting experience in that
I recognized how religion is very useful
at committing good and healthy
communities in fact you know in the
religious communities are demonized a
lot sometimes fairly I think oftentimes
fairly and then sometimes unfairly you
said there are some benefits to to that
form of organization
and it provides benefits to the people
to the members of that community and
it's hard to replicate that
um without these kinds of values
um tying you together yeah so I think
that's going to be a challenge
um but you know um to end on a kind of
an optimistic note I think human beings
are very adaptable
and yes technology is throwing a lot of
problems at us very quickly which makes
things difficult to make it's difficult
for us I think to adapt quickly
um
but it is very possible that we do it's
very possible that we come
you know immune to the kind of siren
songs of of social media and like the
online world and find a way back to
something a little bit more healthy
foreign